[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
very very excited and blessed to be
talking about imaging the cosmos with
adaptive optics and so much more we have
dr. Frank Marquis joining us on the show
hello hi how are you thank you so much
super exciting me thank you for coming
on thank you for Jill Jill tarter for
introducing us we love SETI so much
thank you Jim
Thank You Jill Thank You Jill thank you
seth shostack all these awesome people
we've had on the show that have been
teaching us about space and the cosmos
and exploration we're really excited to
have you now I'm Franck's background for
everyone so it was it was 11 years at UC
Berkeley in astronomy 12 years with SETI
and astronomy exoplanets
outreach all this great work and now 2
years with unis stellar that are
democratizing citizen science we have
this beautiful telescope here that we're
gonna be unpacking the tech and all this
cool stuff as we as we chat we're gonna
get to this later a little bit later
down the line but we're gonna we're
gonna start with your you know your
career and all the cool stuff about IO
and asteroids and exoplanets and even
before we get to that I want to ask you
because we love asking our guests this
question at the beginning is this big
history take on reality ok we find
ourselves as stewards of Earth after
this long period of evolution and what
is your current synthesis on the state
of humanity woof that's a very deep
ocean and he's gonna take me one hour to
that now I'm gonna my short is that I'm
a very optimistic person and in fact
despite all the criticism we hear about
all the challenges we have right now I
think we are in the golden age of
humanity
because we read the moment where our
planet is covered with all these human
who have all these great ideas and we
are all connected with thanks to the
Internet and we are exchanging ideas way
faster that what we used to do think
about it 400 years ago if I wanted to
send you and just a comment that would
take me retaking it mounts to a letter
to come to you right so the speed now is
like instantaneous so we can basically
exchange information very quickly so our
humanity as human being we are working
together to solve our problem and yes
true we have a lot of challenges climate
change is the big one we have a lot of
political instability in the world
ultimately we won't work together to
solve them and I love living in this
moment in this era because I've seen to
the before internet and I've seen after
internet I am Telling You I love being
in the after internet because I see the
acceleration of the pace of ideas and
exchange in the world
that's a beautiful synthesis I love how
you target the you're talking about the
paradigm of collective learning and the
dissemination and communication of
information and knowledge being much
more accelerated now and that being a
huge way that we're being able to
advance our ideas and creativity faster
around the world I like that a lot and
the you know the globalized world also
makes it easier to distribute these
these products and ideas and services
around as well I like I like how you
took us there okay so now let's let's
jump into what got you excited about
astronomy when you were young how did
you figure this out about yourself and
then get on your path UC Berkeley and
whatnot
well let's long story and once again I'm
not gonna tell all of it I'm just gonna
I do remember when I was a kid my father
bought me a small telescope and I look
through this telescope I saw the planet
Jupiter and Saturn
I do remember vividly as well at once he
brought me to a telescope to see a lunar
eclipse and before you do now eclipse
you also look through the big telescope
it was introduced Observatory at the
time and I saw the ring of Saturn yes
and I do remember that vividly and I
still have this image information in my
retina I think because that's been the
moment where I realized wow there is
stuff over there and his planets in his
world and that's kind of changed the
vision I have as a kid and every time I
was looking at the sky I was wondering
there is a planet maybe over there we
didn't know what it was planet at the
time but I was looking and stars and
speaking about planets and words and
then of course I started reading science
fiction Asimov it's been one of the big
science fiction I read of science
fiction writer I read read a lot of the
dune I've heard a lot of books of
science fiction and talk about science
fiction with my friends and from science
fiction to the Stars of course I went to
astronomy and a tsunami was not really
kind of I mean I loved astronomy but
I've been very quickly disappointing by
telling my telescope and so I wanted to
do astronomy I wanted to do astronomy to
change astronomy to make a tsunami
better and a very long story but let's
shotting it I I went to see a professor
at University of Toulouse called Sylvia
vauclair and I remember I was I was
finishing my bachelor in mathematic at
the time and I wanted to go back to
physics and astronomy and she told me
you know maybe you should considered
working on something related to data
processing powerful new optics what we
have there is something called adaptive
optics and adaptive optics is a way for
us as soon
to get an image of the the often a
target like if you telescope the
chromebase telescope in space I remember
she introduced this to me like that
I was wondering how do they do that it's
not magical there is an atmosphere above
us how do you do this well the moving
target a moving target and the basically
adaptive optics is the way to do this
compensation this correction in real
times yes and that's basically excited
me because that finally we'll have a
telescope where we'll be able to see
details in the cosmos and the world to
see moons and asteroids activity on Io
and all of this that's why I started
that's so good that you had that
influence that pushed you into adaptive
optics and in further engage you in
astronomy and I love how you know you
have that same story as so many
including myself of seeing Saturn's
rings and that the sense of awe that
comes from that is just profound and
that's its own world like you said and
that's so interesting to me to every
single one of these celestial objects in
even just our solar system is its own
world and that's so exciting to think
about and to be able to image them
accurately precisely so important and
then you got passionate about that and
pursued it so now you know okay I want
to I want to also mention another one of
the kind of principles that you brought
up here was that adaptive optics is
basically the one of the one of the most
important keys if not the most
potentially important key and in the
data processing side of imaging and
there's a lot of variables that go into
it like you started pointing out I'm
sure we're gonna unpack them more
especially as we get into you in a
stellar and whatnot but okay so how did
that lead you into the UC Berkeley and
then into the SETI well we went so I did
my PhD yet
so the European Southern Observatory I
was working at the 3.6 meter telescope
in lasya a very interesting PhD because
I was spending two weeks or three weeks
sometimes at the summit in the middle of
the desert of Atacama stocking only two
astronomers and then going down to
Santiago that's where I was living to
have a social life and also to travel so
my work as a PhD candidate was mostly as
related over there and learning how to
use adaptive optics how to process other
images coming from adaptive optics and
this was the first adaptive optics
system available in to the community so
we have astronomers for all around the
world coming to this place to use this
dissident robotics system its name was
adonis that was the name of the adaptive
optics system and i spend a lot of my
time fixing it making sure it works
it was a prototype we had this very
complex detectors that nobody have
really used they were coming from the
French military for some parts that we
don't really mean already know how they
were working working so my PhD was about
this learning how to use adaptive optics
and feature the capability of adaptive
optics for the solar system for the
study of bodies in our solar system
so we observed Uranus and so satellites
around it observe Cleopatra and so that
Cleopatra was made of two moon of urine
now Cleopatra is an asteroid as an
asteroid which has a very typical dog
boat dog bone shape that was sown Shane
Boone is one of the more common asteroid
shapes of shape that we have see more
and more now the by elevated shape we
call that it was by two components in
everything and then we so yeah and then
I after my PhD I basically got a phone
call from in Kiribati a professor at UC
Berkeley who
telling me that the United States is
creating what we call the center for the
TV optics
and I wanted to hi all the people have
been working in adaptive optics around
the world so we all met in fact in the
US colleagues of mine were working in a
Y or in pass in Caltech or what UC
Berkeley and and I work at the Keck
telescope at the time the first five
years the large 10 meter plus telescope
on the top that energy and then here we
have a huge even adaptive optics is
there with an grandad soon as a scale we
went from 3.6 meters and that was
fantastic because then suddenly you have
the capability of a 10 meter about yours
in terms of resolution power so you can
see volcanoes on Iowa yeah this parts so
crazy but ok before we get there two
things first is it's crazy that you're
you're pointing out this very
interesting aspect to to your PhD work
but likely many people pursuing their
whatever their thesis is in many ways
they surround themselves in sometimes in
just small groups of the people that are
building like the adaptive optics system
for you and then you guys how many weeks
six to eight weeks at a time yeah
sometimes
so like six to eight weeks at a time
you're giving your mind the ability also
to be quiet because if you were going
out all the time if you were always
around other chatter it would be very
potentially distracting but you gave
your mind that time to kind of hone in
and get really good at the craft some
people can't handle that they need to be
around other people that are not PhDs
but so that's very interesting and then
the next thing that I thought was very
interesting is the United States
adaptive optics what was it again the
Group C FAO the Center for the TV optics
center for adaptive optics EF AO funded
by NSF
found funded by the National Science
Foundation okay so how cool is it that
then they went and I
I do the United States identified and
the NSF identified that there were
brilliant people around the world
working in adaptive optics put them
together and then you realized again
that you know nothing and then other
people know so much yeah and that you
can learn from each other and whatnot
and I'm sure that then you started
talking teaching us about what was going
on at kick in Hawaii okay so when you
start putting together these yeah with a
10 with a 10 meter mirror for absorbing
light you can reflecting light you can
really see the volcanoes on Io IO is the
fourth largest moon of Jupiter it blows
us to Jupiter closest to Jupiter it's a
very special one has like four hundred
volcanoes oh yeah yeah and it it shoots
sulfur in like plume soft looms blooms
of salt as your face is with version
aerated every 10 million years basically
it's a very young surface there is no
craters on it because so the a volcanic
activity is so intense that the
intestine tires your face is young and
is volcanic structures on it so when I
use the three point six meter telescope
we observe IO and we saw this colorful
fans powerful flash coming up so I
remember at this map and I used very
complex that are processing to see this
and I was not really sure I was a young
student at the time and I was not really
sure that I was seeing something real oh
I was it was an artifact of my data
processing we were very lucky because at
the time we have an artificial satellite
the Galileo in orbit around Jupiter
which was observing IO at the same time
and one day we got a human image from
the Galileo spacecraft and his galley
respects our observe IO the same side
that we observe from the ground and I
could see that all my tiny spot where
seen by the Galileo spacecraft and I
have the cover of
very famous print original where
basically of the two images adaptive
optics Galileo spacecraft and you can
see the two volcano the ring of Fire's
of Io volcanoes on this images that look
kind of similar so that was the first
step yeah we can see volcanoes from the
ground but a huge scientific
confirmation and yet what's the half
Callaway and it so yeah that was
basically what we needed to confirm that
we cannot indeed find a civil knose on
the from the ground using adaptive
optics then we so then I use the Keck
telescope so when we observe are you
with the Keck telescope it's another
order of magnitude because the size is
bigger and it was a better adaptive
optic system so the resolution were
three times better in terms of image
quality was even less blurry okay and
the first observation the first night we
observed nineteen of february 2001 I
know this because it's kind of a big
deal a big moment for my that was the
first time I was observing a catch so we
saw Iowa so this beautiful satellite and
we observe it two days later io orbit
around Jupiter showing the same sent
image video so if you in eighteen hours
roughly so if you yeah so if you observe
it 24 hours later yeah it's a fast it's
very close and this Jeff cross with his
gigantic planet and yes Europa which is
forcing you to have this eccentric orbit
so when its orbiting around it's
basically being squeezed all the time
that's why come from the volcanic
activity engine because the the
interview of I will squeeze all the time
and and this this squeeze is not
perfectly elastic material is work this
heat has to escape and the escape using
volcanoes making
volcano so that's the geological and
astronomy science together yeah yeah so
we so two days later the same kind of
hemisphere and it was completely
different
that was his gigantic spot in the meter
we probably were prompting on the on the
star at the time because it was so big
that we would like oh we made a mistake
and we pointing a stuff and then I look
at the low level and I saw IO and this
was kind of a gigantic pimple on the top
of higher and that was the that was a
volcano plume a plume it's not a plume
this one is what we saw the heat of the
volcano at the time anything it took me
months to find out that what we observe
one of the most is the fact the most
energetic eruption I've ever seen on Io
yeah it was very young in probably just
happen in less than a few days so we saw
something super bright like the
beginning of a probe a brighter it's
cool in 24 hours an area as big as Los
Angeles where covered with magma on the
surface of this tiny satellite that size
really
yeah that's available whoa okay so we're
you know this is a very fascinating
celestial object in our solar system
because it's the most geologically
active we hypothesize and it's we're
pretty sure and you have to do the hard
thing about checking all these other
observatories is that you have to pick
where you allocate your time because you
can only unless you have thousands of
these kept because you only have one of
these ket's so - I guess but that you
that you can when you want to study an
asteroid you have to you know set
everything up and wait for the window
and look you need to write a proposal of
people that it's interesting research
they tell me them talk to them about it
it's kind of lobbying sometimes and then
you get the rest of time and sometimes
you get half a day and it's cloudy
anyway I'm face that's right round based
versus the in orbit observation okay
because we can you know we have to we
have to do part two together because
there's just too much cool stuff about
your work to expand and I want to make
sure to get to at least this first light
layer of a lot of your stuff but then we
can go second third layer it's such a
more later because you also you know you
did asteroid discoveries you did a lot
of work with IO and IO imaging and then
also um exoplanets and this is what we
have here we have a we have like an
artist rendering of what the the
Trappist exoplanet system looks like and
and there's how many there seven of them
yeah it's seven of seven exoplanets
orbiting a dwarf is love the star and
this is a how many light years like
thousand yeah something like that
it will figure it out but this is good
so this is this is one of the Kepler and
k2 and and just test is currently up and
doing work as well in exoplanet
surveying and so um you have you have
another project project blue as well
which is very exciting project blue is
about teach us about project blue the
teachers about the importance of yes
before I go to predict okay when we get
to that when we should adapt to your
ticks we could observe bodies in our
solar system we started thinking who we
observe a planet around another star
using adaptive optics and in fact there
is one person I've been thinking a lot
about that his name is Bruce McIntosh
he's a professor at Stanford University
a moment but when I moved to the US
Bruce was probably a researcher at
Livermore and we had this kind of secret
meeting where we basically exchange
information you remember you've
mentioned that we soon you have all
these people who didn't know yeah before
they were like the top strong adaptive
optics and then I meet other people also
for they will talk in adaptive up yeah
and we all realize that we all have
different components
give up the circle so we have this
meeting it was at UC Berkeley and in
this meeting we basically brainstorm
could we observe a planet like Jupiter
we have an adaptive optics system if yes
how and people start thinking about it
we we started putting together concept
of an instrument using what we call
coronagraph which in this case we hide
the star and then we see the surrounding
of the star and we improve what we call
the contrast to reach the point where we
can see an object which is a million
times fainter than the star and that's
the challenge for jupiter-like exoplanet
and then created G by the Gemini planet
in major yes and this instrument is now
in operation and now we can see planet
like Jupiter young Jupiter around nearby
star so now we had get to the second
step
yes what stay on G pi I forgot we should
hit G pipe and do the project go yes yes
so Jeep I started in 2013
yes and what we did what we've been
doing g pi is to observe all the bright
star in the southern hemisphere because
G pies in the in Chile so he can see the
southern hemisphere sky and look for
planet like Jupiter using G pie and we
found a few of them we found in 2015 51
never done it B which is one of the is
the planet that really looked like
Jupiter when I see we see it's very
important I clearly say that the world
see he I'm using it on purpose
we saw photons coming from this planet
into our detector so if I show you a
picture you will see a dark hole this
where the star is you will see the
planet and we can even see the planet
moving now because we are five three
years of observation so we see the
planet moving in orbit around its star
seeing it's very important in fine
astronomer because when you see you get
photons from the body and what you can
do is to spread the light what we do
call what we do what we call
spectroscopy and by looking the color of
the
you know what type of gas there is on
this planet the temperature of this
planet and now we know that we have seen
the first plant jupiter-like exoplanet
using GPI that was a big deal in 2015 I
think is still a big deal because it's
not that a long time ago yes and we
continue this survey and we're searching
more and more of those ago and we will
find more and more of those jupiter-like
exoplanet probably in the future yes ok
so there's there's a couple things that
you said here so we kind of we were
talking a bit about the difference
between having a ground-based telescope
and then having a telescope like Kepler
so then you don't have to deal with so
many adaptive optics when you're on the
ground as when you are in space is
easier in space there's more adaptive
optics to deal with like atmosphere and
there is no distortion coming from the
atmosphere on the ground you have varies
in space in space we also need adaptive
optics craft on some of the reasons yes
well we're still doing moving objects
yes yes okay so then okay so then your
um your work then you know with UC
Berkeley with the adaptive optics and
then with starting with SETI as well and
then doing more work with the exoplanets
with GPI so this is the Gemini planet
imagine imager okay so 2013 this is
built in Chile and the Andes Mountains
in Chile and then again this is kind of
one of those things there's only a
couple of these there's only three of
them on the planet that can do things
like that can image the the direct image
of the exoplanet because you're doing
the choreography that you said so your
your versus the the transit photometry
of like a Kepler telescope where you're
just looking at the dimming in the in
the light to see the planet going in
front of it here you're actually looking
at the composition of the atmosphere
with GPI and these other two on earth
and like so again it's really hard to
you put the proposal in it's a good it
was always work like you were describing
earlier
okay so G PI was 2013 until 2017
we still apparent operating Shiva at the
moment in the southern hemisphere and
his plan to have a jeep I like
instrument in another hemisphere in a
why probably to be able to do the same
survey for the Northern Star so that's
the next step but in fact we already
think about the view we are already
thinking about the future we love
challenges right if I'm an astronomer is
because I like to do stuff which are
very difficult and the next step is to
get a planet to get an image of a planet
like Earth yes that's what we want to do
now now we know that adaptive optics can
do jupiter-like exoplanet let's try to
get to the contrast of 1 billion to see
a planet like Earth in orbit around
another star yes okay quick teach us you
know there's because there's thousands
of now data points that you're looking
through with what Kepler and k2 have
discovered what Tess is discovering
you're looking at all these data points
we know there's thousands of exoplanets
now and that a decent amount of them
actually we hypothesize about one in
five is what is it one in five stars has
an earthlike exoplanet so so this is a
lot of possibility and so but there's
one specific star system that is close
to us Alpha Centauri the prop Proxima
Centauri this this it's a triple star
system yeah it's only 4.3 light years
away versus it's the closest star system
to us versus all the other ones that
we've been looking at our much further
hundred thousand even more light-years
away so we have the possibility of
imaging that and finding the earthlike
exoplanet with what with what you're
doing with project blue so you have G PI
for the Jupiter liking the planet yes
and the next big project is to measure
planet like earth
in orbit around Alpha Centauri so people
in we are interesting in Alpha Centauri
for multiple reasons first because we
extremely lucky because Alpha Centauri a
and B we can call them regal regal can
Therese and Tony man that's the official
name now our sunlight exoplanet they're
very similar to our Sun the same color
the same mass so if there is life on the
planet in orbit around Alpha Centauri a
and B it's very likely that this life
will will have the same type of
chemistry dollars because it's receiving
the same light some vegetation for
instance so these are one interesting
part the second part so close that it's
easy to see but easy it's easy to see
the planet because it's much closer to
us the third part and the first point is
that it's very it's very close system I
mean 4.2 4.3 light years is not that
much the size of the galaxy is hundred
thousand in light-years in diameter so
we're talking about something very close
it looks far away now like a miracle I
look far away from Europe 400 years ago
so now we are scaling our hour of our
perception okay we now with now we don't
think that Jupiter is that far away from
us as tsunami will just tell you here is
only 5 au 4 au from us it's not that
much we can go there right so maybe one
day we will be able to go to Alpha
Centauri a and B so what we are doing
astronomical at the moment is read the
map the map of what's up what what do we
what we have around us we see bright
stars okay because they're close and
what we want to do is to have a map to
give to the next generation next
generation and map telling them here
there is a planet like Earth that's
where you have to go love it that's our
job
cartography I don't want to be the pilot
in the airplane
I don't want to do any of these speak
I'm mark Hager I will tell you the
cartographer doing the the map for the
next general election raishin
story yeah that's such a good way to
tell the story is to hit the next hand
the handoff to the next generation is we
have where cartographer we've mapped
this out now this is where there that we
had very old map I don't know you have
been to the Vatican don't very old the
Matic Vatican Museum name is very old
map from the new world record that they
may not very accurate sometimes that's
why the French sword with Jana to to the
English they thought that he was he was
he was a time there was nothing after
now we know that the American continent
is huge right so those map we are doing
them now because they're gonna motivate
the next generation go there yes
so Project Blue is about collecting
lights coming from an earthlike
exoplanet in Iran alpha Elrond Alpha
Centauri project boo is about giving
indication of the existence of a planet
like Earth around this Alpha Centauri a
and B it's about giving to the next
generation a direction something to
dream about because when you see a tiny
blue dot an orbiter on a bright star far
away from us you have you will have the
motivation to go there and probably
someone some kids very young kid instead
of having the haha moment when he saw
the Saturn rings we'll have this haha
moment when we see this picture and he
may want to become an engineer and they
want to dream about how we could go fast
and how to be will be able to go there
interesting so this is the next overview
effect we had the overview effect of
seeing the Earth from moon and that's
the big aha moment for us and then now
this is the next aha moment 5060 ish
let's hope years later is this aha
moment of seeing
a earthlike exoplanet orbiting us the
closed star system to us and then giving
them the motivation to become the
engineers designers ops peeps to get us
there and probably the next generation
we'd have an app or some dhol reality
set and they will look at this auto
materiality said that we look at the sky
and this map will be implemented and
they will be able to this oh my I just
thought about having unis stellar in my
perception that would be so cool to have
telescopic abilities within my vision
and the adaptive optics oh my gosh that
would be so cool Wow okay okay let's get
to unis stellar but even it's the
motivation of Hugh Stella is not too far
away from what you just said yes please
our goal is really to bring back the sky
to the people I mean if you look the sky
right now from the city where 80% of the
people are living now you don't see any
percent of humans of the 8 almost 8
billion of us live in Metropolis
metropolises yeah so the sky is not very
nice now because we use all this
artificial light to light the street and
our houses and at the end the sky the
stars are slightly disappearing you see
like for right next to the ocean which
is pitch dark yeah and we can still only
see yeah yeah so so we want we basically
this is a mega be a big problem for for
for Humanity I think because if you
don't have the sky you don't have to you
don't have the view of the sky you don't
dream you don't dream about what's what
is there and people like me you become
astronomer because one day they asked
this question by looking at the sky from
the from the countryside yes yes they
will not have this moment so Eunice Tara
is all about bringing back the sky to
the people so for this we created this
what we call digital telescope and I I
can explain the technology if you want
so maybe we can just get there after we
play this and actually just before we
play I just want to say bringing the sky
back to the people bringing the cosmos
back
imaging the cosmos of these adaptive
optics and there's just such a big
contrast between seeing 10 stars in San
Francisco and being in the middle of
nowhere and when there's the moon when
you can't see the moon too because then
that brings a lot of light from the Sun
reflecting off of it but when you can
see just literally a billion stars
because you're in the middle of nowhere
there's nothing quite like that for ego
door fee I think there's nothing quite
like that maybe some very deep
psychedelic experiences deep meditation
experiences but so bringing the sky back
to the people we'll get to some of the
tech stuff here in a moment let's yeah
because to be able to start just to be
able to see in in these 80% of humans
that live in Metropolis is a baking
leverage adaptive optic technology to
see the cosmic perspective of these of
the stars in the light polluted areas is
so crucial okay so we have yeah let's
let's go ahead and let's play the Nvidia
we have yeah uni Stella's telescope is a
smart connected consumer device that
amplifies light to reveal the hidden
wonders of the universe
leveraging its worldwide network of
users it allows anyone to contribute to
science as they observe X a planet
transits supernovae and much more making
astronomy the science that will unite us
all
yes so this is that you just had that
you know that side-by-side thereof
and that was even though that was even
pretty gracious on the left side because
more normally we don't even get that let
it let alone because that would give
them and give us them because that that
I'm curious about the size like what is
this you know size of the mirror the
adaptive optic technology all this kind
of stuff but you know you got inspired
to make this in the first place you have
to have a team you have to work with
yeah so there is no adaptive optics in
this in this telescope we have been
using the technology that professional
tsunami has been using for years and we
put it into this this disease this
device its integrated it's easy to use
everybody will have acts will be able to
observe the star with it
when one of the co-founder Arno is the
one who got basically the idea of the
immense vision the immense vision it's a
concept of putting together stacking
together images in real time in that has
been connected with this device into
this the into the camera here and then
it's projected into the electronic
eyepiece here yes okay so the idea here
is that you you mimic anime the image
you see with the eyes yes but by
stacking them you enhance the
sensitivity yes okay so you basically
see with you eyes like if you had a one
meter class telescope in you garden in
terms of sensitivity week that we reach
this type of sensitivity so the optics
that you haven't here stacking is
stacking the amine with time in real
time of the same patch of sky that you
look yeah and that makes a the enhanced
yeah we've we can show maybe a video
what we see with the telescope I'm not
gonna say where we are so that's
basically the Orion Nebula at the moment
that's it's a video taken with a phone
into the eyepiece so that's why we what
you see with it that's the Orion Nebula
that you're taking with your iPhone
through the through the piece and
we are there in Las Vegas so here they
really illustrate the power of this
telescope even if you have like
pollution runners by using this
technology and by using a complex
process processing that removed the
background and so on we can stack images
and get to the sensitivity sufficient to
see nebulas from Las Vegas in nebulas
from Las Vegas yeah so this is an iconic
nebulas into in the northern hemisphere
of course in the constellation of Orion
so this this has been shown around we
have been like showing this telescope
around demos in in Las Vegas in San
Francisco in LA in Las Los Angeles etc
and Marseille as well so the company has
been designing this it's based in
Marseille but we have offices here in
San Francisco
okay so Marseille and San Francisco is
Eunice stars - headquarters offices yeah
and you have how many team members now
are working on this now we have 13
people 13 people and then you guys sold
2000 of these TV scopes on your
crowdfunding campaign and then that's
about three million dollars of funding
to be able to keep working on the
engineering and get them out by the end
of 2009 the 2019 yeah our backers will
receive them earlier we start we start
shipping a cute cutie Q to 2019 great we
will have this telescope will be
available on the market in 2019 exactly
in 20 and 2019 and the cost approx do
you know yet Rena is our website for two
thousand two thousand dollars yeah and
that is quite it's becoming quite like
democratized in terms of ability to
because that cost is just gonna keep
dropping as well for the technology is
gonna keep getting better the costs can
keep even better eventually in the in in
our own optics like we were saying
earlier this is crazy though in the
middle of light polluted Las Vegas so on
the tech side
you said you're doing the image stacking
the real-time image stacking plus you're
also you're pushing the light pollution
off as well so it's kind of like two
things it's two things yes we process
individual image such as we take we
remove the light pollution and the
effect of the rotation of earth because
earth spins rotating so the skies orbit
is rotating as well and then we stack
images that's basically the image we see
is the image made of the true photon
collected by the telescope at the time
of the observation in fact you can see
if you look at the video maybe we can
see the video you will see there is a
satellite that that flew nearby yeah
that one yep you see here sorry
was it a little back slightly back and
you we see it - line you see oh there's
the - line you around stalker that's an
efficiency like whoa whoa so it's in
this so if you're watching it's at the
top left side of the Orion Nebula and
for those that are just listening we're
able to actually see that's one of our
satellite yeah yeah so that's so that's
truly straight that it's life that's
really you really see what's happening
at the moment in the sky we no cheating
here we collecting two photons coming
around oh that is so crazy
yeah normally you can't see let alone a
nebula but it's satellite from yeah
that's crazy so and we also making such
as everybody can use it I mean what's
the size mirror in here
4.5 inches 4.5 inches okay and it's a
small earth wax it takes the light
camera here there is a computer on board
here that calculates in real time the
batteries here batteries here and there
is a projection device here in the
projection the way you can also see the
image on your phone okay so also
reflects the white into the camera and
then the camera
the image here and I am being have to
process it and the processing the
computer is kind of it's in there okay
interesting and then this is all
coordinated to you know remote and phone
yes so you can show me your phone if you
can show there is a video that showed
the phone and how the so you you are
going to get an application that's we
can run it now if you want that's gonna
show targets that are visible at the
time of you where you located yes
you select the target and the telescope
would basically automatic automatically
point toward the target he has his own
library of stars so you will be able to
tell you yes I'm in the right position
instead start integrated and taking data
this is a real observation with the Uni
Stella telescope of the dumbbell nebula
for instance there is no high quality
yeah so he can yeah of course
awesome so the the phone gives you a
list of target you select the target the
telescope point to other to the sky
finally these on library of sky where
it's located find the target start the
integration and you can see this the the
nebula here the dumbbell nebula into the
eyepiece or on your phone as well and
you can share the image as well that's
great to be able to tell people a I'm
observing right now and this is what I
saw and this is this is a very this is
very cool because you can actually see
what Ronnie we're good
we're gonna go okay it's all good we
this is this is a c'est la vie you know
yes our phrase so great so it's okay so
this is very cool because you can see
which stars that you can are stars with
slash nebula slash all this cool stuff
that you can go explore celestial bodies
and objects and then then autonomously
once you select you will move unis
cellar moves into that and it starts
doing the adaptive optic processing and
then you're getting the image and the
eyepiece on the phone you can share it
inspire other people to get look at it
show you that you can work together
maybe we can show the next the picture
of Earth that we have because city is
being extremely interesting in
partnering with weave Yoona Stella
because we realize that with this tiny
telescope we get to a sensitivity like
if you had a one meter class telescope
so people can use it to observe targets
in the sky when they do camping and so
on and joy and joy with their friends
but they can also do wind science and
the real science I have is the next
picture this is cool I just want this
okay yeah yeah thanks so that's
basically an observe a values target
that we observed with the EBS cup of
different bodies so you can run your
recognizer and 42 the Orion Nebula here
this is the ring nebula this is the
dumbbell so those are real observation
this is a comet that was passing nearby
earth last year in May so this is like
doing the citizen science to make a
massive library a catalog of those
bodies you have the bodies yeah so this
is a cartography that's happening again
so in real time to is very important
because this changes like if if there
are supernovae is happening we've missed
them these are moments that we've missed
in the cosmic history and so to be able
to map everything it's so important yeah
so let's go to the next slide which
illustrate the science that we want to
do so what the point here is that now
we're gonna we're gonna we are going to
have a network of those EB scopes
everywhere on this planet yes and we
hope to have people motivated to do to
do to participate to scientific campaign
so when you're gonna get you endoscope
you're gonna become citizen astronomer
and you can you could if you want should
choose you will get notification about
events happening in the sky like a new
comet has been discovered yesterday do
you want to observe it you try to
telescope you bit outside you will be
able to see a telescope even if you have
a network you're observing and you get a
notification
about a new comet which has just
happened or just been this discover a
new supernova oh you maybe even the
first person to observe the afterglow of
a gamma-ray burst this will be possible
with this telescope I love it these are
the only notifications I will enable on
my inter - yeah and a lot is happening
in the sky yeah it's it's interesting
because now we have all these surveys
that observe continuously the sky and I
have a hard time keeping track for
instance all the stuff happening like
new new bright stars popping up Neulasta
Road new comets the flyby of an asteroid
the an asteroid recently as this kind of
weird activity and becoming a comet and
we don't really know why because ie has
two tails on the top of that so that's
even more complex so this is happening
at the moment and with this you will be
able to see it while you recording data
for the CTS from SETI Institute
astronomer so as an astronomer if I'm
interesting in European are getting more
data of a new transit of Jupiter like
exoplanet I will be able to ask the
network to collect observation and they
will take people will take data for us
send us the data and in return we would
send them basically processing that
process data with a kind of an
explanation what's happening or or some
and as a very crazy idea we have is to
like 400 people to observe a same
comment the same time yes today we're
gonna do a mega a night we can observe
this comet yes and we send this
notification to 400 people on this
planet and form them on that will
observe it and then we put them together
imaged from all different angles of
Earth as well put all those images
together we're gonna we are going to get
the best picture of a comet
they can weave all this data even with
some three-dimensional ability to tweak
and look I was just I was this funny
that you because I what I was thinking
when I wanted to say was
owning the unis stellar being inside of
a place like this recording studio you
couldn't do it with it
but most of the homes again metropolis
is so I don't know if this is quite you
could leave it on your balconies or
whatever but the idea is that you could
keep you in a stellar powered all the
time outdoors and then you can just
enable while I sleep for the eight hours
for the team of unis stellar to be using
this for imaging in hundreds of
thousands of them across the planet
using them for energy and then we're
talking about really building the
catalog oh that's that's exciting
we are thinking I'm gonna give you a
huge hug after I love it amazing school
as well they will have a new East LA
Tennis Club you want to observe
something like a comet and tonight it's
cloudy well you can ask us get access to
other unis tell our telescope you will
be able to do your observations a uni
stellar telescope somewhere in Morocco
yeah we'll have actually have a clear
clear weather you know maybe have access
to it so yes we are thinking about that
as well oh oh I love I love the endless
possibilities with this it's so great
there's so many possibilities that we
don't know which one first I think
though I guess first and foremost the
most important thing is to get the
message out get more people to support
you guys and then have you guys work on
making the optics better decreasing the
cost making the autonomous systems
better convincing people to leave them
outside overnight cover you know if it's
gonna be clear and not making out so
it's can sustain water damage in case in
your bonne chance rains all this kind of
almost kind of stuff I guess just to get
more people to want to there's so many
people that have a income ability to be
able to help support you guys so that's
very very important the amount of
citizen science and what's possible with
and just and this this this in very many
ways reminds me of how artifacts and
archaeology of the human species has
been lost so much has been lost because
it's just done it's gone
erosion etc has destroyed it and even of
other animals like paleontology and
stuff of other fossils of other animals
just gone because we haven't been able
to recover it on time so even now
there's a ticking clock of artifacts
disappearing from earth that we need to
go and dig up and get to understand
right big history same thing with you in
a cellar there's a ticking clock of all
this you had the gap there's galaxies
and asteroids and nebulas and all this
kind of stuff that supernovas that are
happening in the cosmos that we can't
log fast enough into our catalog of
cosmos of the big history perspective
and that's like it reminds me it's like
cosmic archaeology in a sense and yeah
so I have something that made an idea
you know I work at SETI Institute so I
have to have something crazy to tell you
right think about it if a species an
extraterrestrial civilization the
technology called civilization slightly
more advanced than us world is gigantic
laser beam to send a spacecraft to
communicate with the station and then
one day this noticed that there is life
on this tiny blue dot around this g-type
star called the Sun I will not call it
the Sun probably very very differently
and I decide to launch the laser pointer
the lasers to us like a pointer like a
beacon saying we are here we are here
they're not gonna do that for a long
period of time because this use a lot of
energy they may do that for a few hours
well maybe you need Stella telescope
we'll catch this in the sky and that's
what we want to do as well we want to be
able to see the sky 24/7 yes because we
want we don't want to miss this
a such visceral signal this will be a
game-changer huge I love how many big
things that you're working on 24/7
cataloguing of the cosmos doing the
earthlike exoplanet orbiting of the
Alpha Centauri star systems that you're
doing the you know G PI and constantly
doing ground-based telescope ik work of
imaging exoplanets and and the
atmospheres of those exoplanets to find
hopefully life we still have yet to
unpack you know what's hopefully gonna
happen with Europa and Enceladus other
potential spots for for life the
colonization of the Moon and Mars and
how exciting that is and what how we do
that
you know geopolitically what are the
protocols we take from our civilization
to the next rock there's so many topics
to still talk to you about and I'm very
excited to have when I'm the doorbell
with about I would we would love to do
part two with you Frank it's such an
honor I have a couple quick questions on
the way out okay first of all I'm very
scientific answers of course and no we
haven't identified but what is your
greatest imagination about life in the
cosmos
my greatest imagination about life in
the cosmos
I feel life is everywhere and that's
what you that I think in fact we will
soon find out that life like back back
to your life microbes are everywhere
it's kind of a natural evolution yes of
any environment and we probably will
find out that there is life on Mars in
the cave of mouth so in the geyser of
Enceladus and we find that life spread
around quickly because rocks with your
rights as bring life around and probably
life is very similar somehow because of
this
and intelligent life is another big
problem that I have I can talk oh this
is an entire hour discussion but one of
the problem I have with intelligence is
that quickly intelligence we try to
replace itself by something mechanical
something which is not biological yes so
I do believe that biological
intelligence is a glimpse into the
evolution of a species because quickly
this biological intelligence will become
technically become an artificial
intelligence we are creating our own we
will create quickly something that will
replace us something that will not don't
need to eat something that we don't need
to to drink I can travel through this
Buddhist through the cosmos as dine cube
wasting the energy of stars for instance
Ron I can't even I can't talk about it
because at what I don't understand is
how come nobody sees what I see that
that we are this intelligence and we are
turning ourselves into these this
different human being and this is
virtual reality and like what you said
just hit the nail on the head as far as
what I understand that the past the
present the future is all happening at
once and all were trying to find it's
just kind of ourselves and did you do it
does that make any sense yes yes yeah
there's there's crucial between what
both of you said it's just that on on
this timeline of what we're experiencing
this biological blip that occurs is very
interesting to me as well because we're
talking on the scale of just a couple
million years as an intelligent life
because after that blip becomes the
artificial intelligent life and when
general intelligence is able to
to go and begin exploring the cosmos I
mean we're talking you know
self-replicating abilities to the extent
of of very strong exploration of the
cosmos
so in colonization of the cosmos of the
galaxies and then can they even get
between galaxies and there's so many
other questions to ask the simulated
realities and are we in one we have to
we have to move we have the world we
know it we're coming into variant 50
times and I just hope the the animals
get to stay and continue to be a giraffe
the Rhinos you know the elephants life
in itself which is seeing it you know
but that's I'm not quite believing that
the human is evolve the human ethics
have to do a good chunk of evolution
left prior to the being able to program
with artificial intelligence I think
there is another path that probably
means we will start thinking very soon
and in fact some people are already
started I already started thinking about
it what about making our our biology
better career changing ourselves the
biological species so we can be for
instance in space changing ourselves
using the CRISPR technology correct our
self faster better and be able to travel
for the star and not having to feel the
effect of the absence of gravity yes
using
what the nature has been were on the
wrong becoming the perfect species that
live on this planet without having to
change it like becoming the smart
dolphin or the smart whales yeah this is
this is the bio and neuro hacking this
is the bio-neural augmentations this is
living as long as as you want because
you constantly state it stay in the age
of being 25 forever there's no there's a
lot still left on pack but this is a
good short bit on on what you want your
thoughts were about that I have to ask
you two more quick
this is simulation so we have to ask are
we in a simulation we cannot answer to
this question scientist of course the
quickest but but what are you're not yet
so I will tell you I cannot it's not a
question that should ask my time
thinking about because there is no way I
can prove it or disprove what about your
wildest imagination
I don't think we are in the simulation
everything the base I would just might
want to see me my world a sensor is that
if we are in a simulation let's enjoy it
and make the simulation even better even
better yes that's right
Amen I do I love it okay last question
is what do you think is the most
beautiful thing in the world
whoo I think it's Earth
because it's an amazing nest of
intelligence and biological species
living together on the very thin layers
the atmosphere and from far away it's a
beautiful planet to see I heard I've
seen pictures I never seed for far away
myself and I wish to be able to do that
so I think that's the most beautiful
thing in the world yeah yeah it could
even be the most divine thing that we
can experience is that we evolved here
in that it's now up to us to do what is
needed in this in the next step of the
evolution of the code of what's
happening Frank what a pleasure this has
been a thank you thank you for all your
work all your working inspiring people
and working on such incredible feats of
technology that we're very excited to
get all around helped get all around the
world and help us hopefully have more
awe and Wonder and pass that along to
children the next generation here's the
cardamom here's the wrap thank you very
much thank you thank you this has been
such such a pleasure please please
everyone thank you so much for tuning in
check out the links below to Frank's
work check out the links to Eunice
teller go and and if you know go go go
and you know get get involved more in
the in the conversations about about
astronomy and about the planetary and
cosmic perspective about really
awakening ourselves and our children or
the next generation get involved in you
guys are still selling please please get
in if you if you can get get involved
with vacuum unistall or get one of these
in your homes and share it with your
communities give us your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode we'd love
to hear from you keep building out the
community everyone thanks Ron for
producing and directing this has been a
lot of fun
we really appreciate appreciate you so
much and everyone build the future keep
supporting the artists and the
entrepreneurs that you
even support yourselves for people like
us our links are below as well support
arson entrepreneur community build the
future we love you very much everyone
and we will see you soon peace
[Applause]
[Music]